Let's assume you've
had COVID-19.
You might believe
you're immune,
in the clear to go about
your normal life
without safety precautions.
But with scattered
reports of recovered cases
testing positive again,
a lot of people are
wondering if it's possible
to develop immunity at all.
So, can you catch
COVID-19 twice?
The thing is, scientists
just aren't sure,
because figuring that out
is a lot more complicated
than you might think.
When a pathogen
like a virus
manages to get
into a human,
their body will
signal an alarm.
This will start
what's referred to
as the innate
immune response
and consists of
physical, chemical,
and cellular defenses
against pathogens.
Often enough, this works,
and the invader is killed,
but sometimes you
need a second attack.
The adaptive immune
response marshals
the special forces:
B cells and T cells.
B cells produce antibodies
that smother the
specific pathogen
so it can't affect
your body's cells.
Shane Crotty: So,
basically, antibodies
kill virus outside of cells;
killer T cells kill
virus inside of cells.
Narrator: So, once your
body fights the pathogen,
what stops you from
having to fight off
the same attack
over and over?
Well, your body
has a secret weapon
to protect you against
any future attacks
from the same pathogen:
memory cells.
Memory cells are
basically the specialized
T cells and B cells that
stick around as guards.
That way, if you
encounter the virus again,
the army will
be readily waiting
to kill that
invader instantly.
This is immunity.
A vaccine works on this
basis by adding dead,
weakened, or fragmented parts
of a pathogen to your body.
Not enough to cause illness,
but enough to cause
your body to
produce memory cells.
Crotty: Normally, when
you have an infection,
it's a race between
your immune system
and the infection.
But if you're vaccinated,
you've already
done the race part.
Your immune system
has already had time
to scale up and
develop immunity.
Narrator: Typically,
you would know
if you have immunity,
either from a vaccine
or knowing you
previously had the illness.
For example, it's relatively
straightforward to know
whether you've had
chickenpox or not
because the symptoms
are highly unique
and very easy to spot.
But let's presume you
know you've had COVID-19.
You now have immunity
and are safe, right?
To test this theory,
one early study
infected monkeys with
the COVID-19 virus.
They then waited till
they tested negative
after the infection passed
and tried to reinfect them.
When the monkeys didn't
become reinfected,
researchers concluded that
after one viral attack,
you would be
protected from another.
But this isn't a golden ticket
to thinking you're immune,
because the
length and strength
of that potential
immunity are unknown.
And where a disease
lies on the spectrum
is influenced
by two things,
memory cell death rate
and virus mutation rate.
Memory cell death rate
tells you at what rate
those memory cells
may be lost over time.
The virus mutation rate
can tell you if the virus
will mutate too quickly
for your memory cells.
The more a virus mutates,
the more unrecognizable
it becomes to your
memory cells.
Determining where
COVID-19
falls on this timescale
is a vital step in
managing its spread.
One indication of how long
its immunity might last
is to look at
other coronaviruses.
Those who have
contracted SARS-1
have been found
to have immunity
for about two
to three years,
and the same time
frame has been seen
in other coronaviruses that
can cause the common cold.
Yet early signs have shown
that this virus tends
to mutate slowly.
But there's another indicator
into immunity
strength and length:
the serology test.
Crotty: The serology
testing is a blood test
for the presence of
antibodies against
that specific virus or
that specific disease.
Narrator: Importantly, these
are tests that can be done
after you've recovered
from symptoms.
Crotty: And you don't
have to know exactly
when that person
was infected.
And so that's a very
powerful way to count
how many people have
actually been infected,
whether they recognize
the symptoms or not.
Narrator: These tests
can measure
how many antibodies
are in the sample
by looking at how they block
or respond to the virus.
These measurements
can help to understand
immunity levels and how
long immunity could last.
For example, studies for
many other viral infections
have found that
the more severe the case,
the longer the immunity.
Basically, the bigger
the infection,
the bigger the
immune response
and more
antibodies in a sample,
which in turn gives
longer immunity.
But this may not hold
true for COVID-19.
Crotty: It certainly
may not be as simple as
if you're positive
for the antibody,
you're protected against
the disease, you're immune.
That's true for
many infections;
it's not proven for
COVID-19 disease.
Narrator: And the
effectiveness of certain
serology tests for
COVID-19 has been mixed.
Some tests are
being misused,
and others were brought
into the United States
before the FDA could
approve them.
The result has been
poor detection rates,
some as low as 20%.
Crotty: You know, these
are the same types of tests
as a pregnancy test.
And so there's no way people
would take pregnancy tests
if they were only
accurate 60% of the time.
Narrator: And there
have been instances
of false positives, which
can be extremely dangerous,
because they
arm people with
a false sense of
potential immunity.
But these problems
aren't universal,
and the FDA has begun
approving a select few
that show much
higher accuracy.
So, with an accurate
serology test,
would you be immune?
Well, one early
Chinese study
found 30% of those who
tested positive for the virus
had little to no
detectable antibodies,
which would suggest that
immunity isn't guaranteed,
though this has been
challenged by another study
that found all
patients tested
had significant
antibody levels.
But other issues
such as age or health
could play into
these responses.
Crotty: Is it gonna
be 0.1% of people
who can get reinfected
three months later?
Or is it going to be a
higher number in the elderly?
Narrator: Once more
accurate and universal
testing is underway,
more studies can begin
to more precisely examine
how long this immunity
may last and who has it.
So our best bet right now
is to keep our distance
and assume we're
not immune at all.